let's get into this week's hey treat
male as is the case most weeks very very
special edition of hey treat male
[Music]
it's like a mandatory transvaginal
ultrasound for your mind Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom alright don't really need to say
much at all about this week's hey treat
male other than it contains a number of
the common hatred mail bingo
keywords let's see if you can pick out
what they are hey feminine David Park
man listening to you speaks your native
language of liberal gay is worse than
all Trump's does you are the direct
product of male feminization David
Pakman you are for sure such a liberal
loser worthless loser who will lose
again for 2020 is that Pakman audience
thieving socialists like him so the
hatred mail bingo that I identify here
here is terrible grammar terrible
spelling homophobia the idea that I am a
socialist and also putting my last name
as Parkman instead of Pakman so [ __ ] you
could conceivably have bingo if you had
the bingo card properly arranged just
from this one Patriot male and as I as I
often do and it's stunning to me just by
mentioning this how many people actually
take advantage of this we have a way for
you to send a middle finger or a
proverbial fu to the hey tree 'it's
which is to use the coupon code hey tree
at 40 when you get a membership and
it'll save you 40% and the idea is that
you are so moved by hatred is a move to
support the program that the hey tree
'it's are directly helping to fund our
show that coupon code is spelled h atri
OT 4-0 and it will save you 40% off of
the membership of your choice at david
pakman.com slash membership